if you were to travel to West Windsor
one of the main places you could go
would be to go to Princeton University
oh she's very close by is a really nice
campus
lots of a lot of a lot of things to do
within art museum there another place
can go would be the grounds for
sculpture over in Trenton oh it's
officially an outdoor museum for
sculptures by many famous artists or
also in trainers at the Trenton War
Memorial which dates all the way back to
the Revolutionary War is when George
Washington crossed the Delaware River to
New Jersey if I were to give him a free
ticket to go anywhere in the world I
probably choose to go to the UK because
in my mind it's a very interesting place
they think they go to see things like
Buckingham Palace the Tower of London
and also the 2012 Olympics are being
held there but you can make it a very
interesting place in my mind I could
favorite places any famous explorer
world later I probably choose
Christopher Columbus because my mind is
a very important man he opened up the
Americas and like the whole Western
Hemisphere to the rest of the world
I like his own way kind of founded this
country and all the nearby countries as
well
well my secret of studying is to read a
lot and watch the news and make sure you
pay attention to everything to see
because it could come up in one of the
questions and its overall everything the
world could be like could be one of the
questions
you